the Federal Reserve just launched a
pilot program for the digital dollar
America's very own Central Bank digital
currency or cbdc and they've partnered
with financial giants like HSBC
MasterCard and Wells Fargo to make it
happen which means the dystopian future
has arrived and if the pilot program is
a success well you can kiss your freedom
goodbye let me explain
implementation of things like a digital
currency that is centralized that's
controlled by the government right that
scares the [ __ ] out of me absolutely
because that's what we're when Maxine
Waters who has been promoting this said
that we need this to compete with China
which is so crazy yeah it's like saying
we need communism to compete with
Communism exactly because that's what it
is yeah if you want to compete with
Communists you have to be a communist
like what like digital currency that's
centralized by the state is terrifying
because they'll connect it to a social
credit score system yeah if they
connected to a social credit score
system Tulsi gabbard I don't like what
you said on The Joe Rogan Experience
we're gonna go and eliminate your
ability to five right you can't fly you
can't travel you can't buy gas anymore
which is what they do in China now when
you hear about a digital dollar you
might think that it's pretty much the
same thing as cryptocurrencies like
Bitcoin however that could not be
farther from the truth with crypto you
have a decentralized transparent
currency that no single person can
control but with the digital dollar you
have the literal exact opposite a
completely centralized currency where
the government can track every single
penny you transact with and their end
game is very clear they want to make
programmable money programmable money
that will allow them to prevent you from
buying a plane ticket or gas or food if
you're not an obedient citizen
programmable money that will put you
your family and your freedom at the
mercy of the governments want to spend
your hard-earned money on a European
holiday sorry we've been tracking your
carbon footprint from the things you buy
and your carbon footprint is just too
big better look next year by the way
click that join button below to watch
our new private documentary on climate
change if the digital dollar is is made
programmable spending money on whatever
you want and having economic freedom
will be a thing of the past the
government can literally program your
money so you don't spend any money on
things they deem as bad
Central Bank digital currencies are the
perfect tool for a very dystopian future
and it's becoming a reality right now
shout out to George Gaiman for covering
the story first I'll link to his channel
below stay dangerous subscribe for more
and let's get into it
[Music]
if you want to conquer the world you're
going to need to eat the right food that
will give you a lot of energy and if
you're like me you love cereal as a kid
unfortunately cereals made by big food
have an insane amount of sugar in them
which is super super bad for you but
luckily I have the perfect solution
magic spoon if you don't know what magic
spoon is you are sorely missing out
magic spoon is cereal that tastes
exactly like the sugary cereal you loved
as a kid except magic spoon has zero
grams of sugar only four to five net
grams of carbs in each serving and a
whopping 13 to 14 grams of protein per
serving which means you can still
indulge in sweet delicious cereal
without a sugar crash and while getting
your protein my favorite flavor has
always been coca it tastes just like the
popular chocolate puff cereal I loved as
a kid is that this one actually gives me
that energy and protein I need but I
have also taken a liking to peanut
butter so let's do this
Magic's gonna sent me their cute new
cereal bowl
or in the milk of your choice
Forbes has called this the future of
cereal and once you try it it's easy to
understand why these cereals are keto
friendly gluten-free grain-free soy free
plus right now magic spoon is giving you
guys five dollars off your own variety
box so you guys can try whatever flavors
you want I highly recommend getting at
least these two all you gotta do is go
to magicspoon.com with coupon code J
trend for five dollars off with the link
below they ship to the US Canada and the
UK there's 100 happiness guarantee so
pause the video and go to magicspoon.com
Jay Tran with code jtran for five
dollars off with the link below thanks
to the magic spoon for sponsoring
another video
to understand just how dangerous
programmable money really is you need to
understand how our current Financial
system works let's say you want to send
your friend a hundred dollars for their
birthday you have your money at bank a
while your friend has an account at Bank
B and in between you and your friends
bank is the Federal Reserve America's
Central Bank when you transfer the 100 a
record of it is kept on your bank's
Ledger another record of the transaction
is kept at the Federal Reserves Ledger
and the transaction is also recorded at
your friend's bank's ledger so right now
each bank has their own Ledger but the
system works pretty much perfectly
there's a very very low likelihood that
your money is going to get lost if you
try to send 100 somewhere so if the
current Financial system works perfectly
fine right now we're talking hundreds of
billions of dollars moving from bank to
bank every single day without fail why
does the government want to change it
why try to fix something that isn't
broken one word control see in the eyes
of the Puppet Masters this current
system is very broken it's very broken
because it doesn't give them any control
they can't control what you or your
friends spend money on sure they can
freeze your account if they have a
compelling enough reason to but they
can't decide when your friend gets to
use that 100 you sent him they can't
decide if he gets their withdraw from an
ATM or not or if he's allowed to spend
it on clothes or alcohol or a hotel room
the only Power the government has over
your money right now is to freeze all of
it or nothing at all there is no in
between but what a digital dollar that
is all Gonna Change with a digital
dollar instead of Bank a bank B and the
Federal Reserve all having separate
ledgers all of it is going to live on
one single Ledger one single blockchain
so when you send a hundred dollars from
Bank a to your friend at bank B the end
result is going to be functionally the
same as the current system we have but
the difference is that one single Ledger
would be completely controlled by the
governments and when everything is
brought onto a single blockchain
controlled by the government they will
be able to dictate whatever they want
just like when you create an nft and you
can dictate how much commission the
artist gets every time an nft is resold
that same functionality will allow the
government to set whatever restrictions
or conditions they want on what you can
do with your money it's not a little too
far-fetched well this is what a Deputy
Governor at the bank of England had to
say about programmable money quote you
could think of giving your children
pocket money but programming the money
so that it couldn't be used for sweets
and quotes ah yes if we allow the
government to adopt a digital dollar the
government is going to program your
money so that you can't buy suites with
them they're probably not going to
restrict literal sweets but maybe
they'll prevent you from buying alcohol
from buying a gas car from buying an
electric car from Tesla because Elon
must piss them off too much they might
prevent you from buying or whatever else
the Masters deem to unhealthy who knows
maybe they will ban sweets this would
give governments power to literally
decide which businesses get to live and
die yes the same people that lie to our
faces to go to war for oil that commit
atrocity after atrocity of her atrocity
that already wastes our money on insane
frivolous spending are soon going to be
able to control what we can or cannot
buy and this is not just something
that's happening in America no no no
Central Bank digital currencies are
becoming a thing all around the world
[Music]
the world economic Forum has been
pushing governments all around the world
to work on Central Bank digital
currencies and digital IDs for quite
some time now their main argument we
needed to punish hate speech and
extremism on social media more
effectively we needed to strengthen our
financial system in times of Crisis like
natural disasters or the next pandemic
we need digital currencies to control
and improve our carbon footprint watch
our private documentary on climate
change by clicking that join button
below it's probably our most spicy one
yet on who profits from pushing climate
change we need Central Bank digital
currencies for the stability of our
economy in Ottawa it would just be so
convenient for you and it seems like
claw Schwab and his Sidekicks at the wef
have been quite persuasive right now
over a hundred governments are exploring
or working on Central Bank digital
currencies China has already begun
working on a pilot project for the
digital nuan that's directly connected
to China's social credit system and
other countries aren't far behind
India's Central Bank has already begun
rolling out a digital version of the
rupee Brazil plans to launch a digital
version of its currency in 2024 Earth
and in July 2021 the European Union
joined the party with the European
Central Bank launching the investigation
phase for the Dijon Euro a digital Euro
would know anonymity because full
anonymity would raise concerns about the
Dijon Euro potentially being used for
illicit purposes of course the potential
launch day for the digital Euro for all
27 European countries is 2026. only
three years away right now if you say
something controversial on social media
or join like an anti-lockdown
demonstration or something if the
government really wanted to they could
contact the bank you have an account at
tell them to freeze your funds then
contact any of your other banks that
have unfreeze your funds but that's just
not very clean and efficient we need
something that at the click of a button
Mary can't buy groceries anymore oh I'm
sorry you said something against the
Main Street narrative sorry you can't
travel by train plane or bus for the
rest of the year what you've eaten me 10
times last month we hope you enjoyed it
because from now on we're gonna limit
the amount you can spend on meat and
fast food to only 20 a month see this
kind of efficiency just isn't possible
right now
[Music]
in 2018 Chinese citizens were blocked
from buying airplane or train tickets
over 22 million times because of the
poor social credit score
these government also restricts you from
buying luxuries if you're not obedient
like how many citizens were barred from
buying business class train tickets or
from booking the best hotels if you
don't pay your bills in time you and
your kids can miss out on the best jobs
in schools like how in 2017 when 17
people refused to do their military
service they were restricted from
applying to high schools or enrolling in
universities or like how One University
student was kicked out because of his
dad's bad social credit score in 2018.
if you own a dog they have a score for
that too if you don't keep your dog in
line on a leash and not barking you
could get it taken away from you quote
those who lost all their points had
their dogs confiscated and had to take a
test on regulations required for pet
ownership end quote after a court found
a Laura's apology insincere the lawyer
was placed on a list and was banned from
buying plane tickets and applying for
credit cards and public transport in
China well take a listen for yourself
people who travel without the tickets or
behave disorderly of smoking public
areas we punished according to
regulations and the behavior
would record a personal credit please
follow the relevant regulations and help
with
[Music]
this is a real announcement made on a
bullet train in China warning you what
will happen if your Disobedience and
there are many many more punishments the
CCP is experimenting with right now see
China is a forewarning a forewarning of
what's to come if Western governments
Implement cbdcs because the natural
follow-up to a central bank digital
currency will be well we can control
people spending now we obviously need
some kind of social credit score to
label people with how else are we going
to determine who to restrict and who not
to restrict
even without the digital dollar America
has already Enslaved the world the
digital dollar will just make it easier
for America to enslave its own citizens
more see after the last few years of
studying money and power I uncovered
something startling poor countries do
all the hard work Asia Africa South
America do all the manufacturing do all
the farming and all the hard labor while
America and the West get to sit back do
nothing and collect all the wealth why
because America the west and the biggest
corporations have figured out a way to
enslave the world to get them to do the
work for love but we're not talking
about traditional slavery with Whips and
Chains No we're talking about a much
more sophisticated form of slavery
Financial slavery shackling countries in
debt printing money slavery through
Rosie sounding things like globalization
and offshoring financial slavery is the
fundamental secret that the most
powerful institutions around the world
used to become successful and if you
want to become successful and Powerful
you're gonna need to understand this and
I expose all of it in my new Master
Class called Financial slavery
masterclass 20 plus lessons all narrated
by me in the same addictive documentary
style format you've come to love and
it's all centered around this
fundamental secret and how you can use
it to gain more power and wealth for
yourself this is the secret they never
wanted you to know this is what they're
afraid to say out loud this is what
they'll never teach you in business
school and you can learn it right now by
clicking the link below and watching the
first lesson for free and on top of that
I wanted this masterclass to be a chance
for you to financially benefit right
away too so on top of all the
life-changing stuff You're Gonna Learn
by enrolling you'll also be able to earn
around 100 for every person you refer to
the master class this is just like
Andrew takes legendary affiliate program
where you'll get step-by-step lessons
and resources on how to promote this
masterclass by posting Tick Tock clips
of my videos we provide you with the
clips we give you instructions on how to
edit them into Tech talks and YouTube
shorts basically we hand hold you
through everything you need to start
earning some commission but instead of
just 25 dollars per sign up like Tate's
program you get four times that at
around a hundred dollars you make some
money we make some money more people
learn about this everyone wins so scroll
down and click the link below to buy now
foreign
[Music]